if i want to make a million if i want to
make a million pounds next year in 2021
obviously against the market
circumstances like what should i be
thinking about
okay here's how you do it everyone ready
so you have to think about units versus
ltv so when i talk about growth
consulting
cash flow consulting i've made you know
a handful of videos about it
when people pay me 50 grand for six
hours i literally break it down to these
two core pieces
which is how much is a client worth how
many do i need to sell
right and if you want to do a million
gross versus a million net so we just
need to be specific here if you're just
looking for a million gross
then you have your ltv at 10k you need
to solve 100 clients
right which means you need to sell two
clients a week 52 right times two give
yourself a little bit of buffer
right so and then i just reverse
engineer from there so if it's
two clients a week and i know that i
close one out of five sales calls then
it means i need 10 sales calls a week
that show and if i know that let's say
your average show rate is 75
then i'm just going to say 15 so it's at
66 to give myself again
at each level i give myself a tiny
buffer so that it makes it realistic
that i'm going to achieve it
so now i need 15 calls a week in order
for me to make
get 15 calls a week what's my average
you know
cost per call yours is like five dollars
uh but for everyone else
you know it's it's a couple hundred
dollars but let's say yours is 50
i would say okay i'm going to safely
budget 75
right uh and it's 15 calls so that's
22.50 per week in ad spend that i need
to spend
uh which means that i'm spending you
know uh divided by
whatever seven is 300 bucks a day
right and so for me to get to and how
many ads do i need to make
to spend a day profitably
probably need to make 10 good ads per
month
and so that means i would block one big
calendar day per month to make all the
ads and the copy and all that stuff
i block out two to four hours a week to
review them you know update the copy
change
you know change creative etc and then
three hundred dollars a day
yields me my 15 calls 15 calls gives me
10 shows 10 shows gives me two sales
and then because of the back end system
that i built i know that my ltv is 10
grand
and that's the game
you